none of you guys are working with Harvey
Weinstein out here but is it actually
common for attractive women to actually
be harassed in the workplace
what are your thoughts
I I would say yes yeah but but with a
caveat that
it depends on the woman's comfort level
because harassment is subjective
so you know for example
you know if you're sending me explicit
messages like yes that's a clear like
delineation of sexual harassment but my
brother actually had an instance where
he was pulled into an HR situation and
you know he had just put his hand on the
back of his assistant and said you know
can you tell them that I need five more
minutes like to go tell the new clients
like just give me a second and that's
innocent innocence so that was an
incident so I think it really just
depends on what you deem sexual
harassment and I feel for guys sometimes
because how do you know where that line
is
I don't know that's subjective but it
can be it can be common and it depends
on the industry too like wine industry
is very very well known for everybody's
everyone's sleeping with everyone yeah I
mean that's alcohol and wine does yeah
exactly so you know you for me it was
kind of I'm cutting a rug I'm new into
the industry I need to you know I need
to learn the sales process and it taught
me an amazing taught me lots of life
lessons yeah um but as a woman you know
you also have to take responsibility for
presenting yourself in a certain manner
I think and making sure that you limit
the opportunities for particular
interactions just in my personal it's
just hard to understand if you're
starting out you're naive 100 you're
still learning the landscape and
navigating how to read people when you
haven't had that experience at that
level so I can understand how sometimes
it you can get yourself in a situation
you're like but how did I get here right
because you just don't have the
wherewithal to understand well you
walked into the room and X Y and Z yeah
I think as us like older women now right
which is experience part of the
experience right yes so I don't know if
it's industry specific I'm sure it is
but I feel that it's almost like just
part of being a woman and it's one of
those things fortunately unfortunately
you know
you have to learn how to navigate and
you have to learn the signs you have to
learn your own boundaries you have to
just kind of grow up and understand that
and you know I have two daughters and so
that's always and and even myself you
know I have a team I deal with I have 99
of them are women you know we're in
child care and I use sweetheart I use
you know I use these words as a term of
endearment and and this environment
nowaday that could be probably
misconstrued and brought back to me in
some way but it's not my intention to
you know offend anybody or you know make
them feel uncomfortable by using some of
those terms of endearment but I do
understand that people are sensitive
um it could be triggering I don't you
know I don't know all of the backgrounds
of everybody so you know it's just like
we're learning we're all still learning
how to be better and how to
um take accountability for ourselves as
well yeah I think you mentioned that
well and I have four brothers so they I
mean I was schooled pretty early on on
how men you know can sometimes work and
they were very protective I kind of knew
how just men were locker room talk so
I'd imagine growing up with all girls
there could like how do you know right
I've had girlfriends who grew up with
all women and like you said it's really
your kind of your own experience and
what you learn from home and bring to
the workplace and how you navigate that
not knowing if a man touches you like
that could really trigger something for
me it's just like oh I think I think
that's also where communication plays a
really big factor especially in the
workplace like to your point earlier you
know if you're using haste sweetie as a
term of endearment that's coming from
your male manager and that makes you
uncomfortable as a woman maybe address
that and say Hey you know I don't like
being called sweetie please just call me
Natalie you know that's my name
right but he's calling someone sweetie
actually like
a problem
for me it depends on the person right if
if you call me sweetie and I'm telling
you that makes me uncomfortable then why
would you continue to want to make me
feel uncomfortable sure if you come out
and say that right right but I feel like
that's like hey how are you honey like
guys like that's not well you have to do
that to me isn't like harassment no
because your intentions were not right
so but in her what you're saying and
then you would just express it and then
it's in your ballpark continue or to
kind of say okay I don't want to offend
her but as a woman but as a woman
sweetie do me a favor all right
okay but as a woman you have to think
about okay what what's going to happen
if I do confront this situation right
what are the repercussions of that that
are that are going to happen and for me
in my situation it was
okay now he's going to be watching
everything that I do he's going to be
writing me up you know it became an HR
issue because he wanted to retaliate and
this this was this was a little bit
older than you also where you know me
too movement was that we can talk about
that that's another subject but that
wasn't a thing back in this first job so
there really wasn't
I think men are a little bit more
cautious now yeah scared I think also
you have to consider kind of what's
leading up to like certain behaviors
like if they're casual with you and
they're like hey sweetie can you help me
with this like I don't think it's deemed
as like sexual harassment but if you're
a guy and you know your eyes are always
wondering and you're always a little
closer than usual and you're always
Whispering a little closer and you're
like hey sweetie like there becomes a
fine line of where it's like okay you're
using it not really for endearment
you're using it to kind of like you know
kind of get closer to you so I think
it's just a matter of also like previous
actions before certain things are done
because women can feel like when men
have like a sexual intention it's not
very hard to like notice right ladies I
don't know if you guys can but it's
pretty it's pretty clear like you call
me sweetie I'm not gonna be like oh my
God sauce is flirting with me like
that's not what I take that as because
if you don't treat me that way you don't
make me feel uncomfortable but if you're
like touching me a little too much or
you're in my ear too much like hey
sweetie it becomes a little bit like
okay now you've crossed line I feel
uncomfortable I'm going to express that
but I think again it's I think today
people are more cautious of things like
this I think also how women react to
certain things it also becomes more of a
kind of like you're putting a yellow
tape in front of the guy like hey like
I'm not okay with that like let's back
off a little bit but again I think it's
also just your actions leading up to you
know whatever it is that comes out of it
yeah I think um
I don't know I've never been I've never
been in this world
I have a sister like yeah so
who are the creepy didn't work I I guess
I'm wondering like this is not one of my
topics that I'm just actually generally
interested in this like is it always
like some dude that hasn't been laid in
10 years that always a married guy
there's a game sometimes it's getting
attention like in your experience what's
the creepy like you're you're running in
for Congress and politics I don't know I
just feel like politicians are creepy as
[__] I don't know but like what's your
experience like who are these people
because in my opinion this is me if you
if as a woman if you're like
if you're like hey I have a boyfriend
and I appreciate whatever you're trying
to do creepy guy but like I'm good
thanks that to me is like all right cool
like move on
right like yeah but that's all men are
like that I think sometimes like who are
these guys that are like no I don't care
that you have a boyfriend I'm a creepy
ass [__] I'm Gonna Keep Going
who are these people I don't think they
have a face
I think it's generally interested I
don't know none of my buddies they're
all different types it's single guys
it's guys that are married with kids
that are unhappy in their marriage
I think look I think a lot of there are
three sides to every story right I think
that a lot of men now are scared
in work environments to even compliment
somebody or even be nice to a co-worker
because of so much of this metoo
movement not saying that some of the
situations weren't valid or there's
obvious
that in a lot of different Industries
however
I think it does come down to a woman's
comfort level uh you know if I'm okay
with locker room talk someone like
Natalie or Sarah might not be and it
might be offensive or vice versa right I
think people have to have just kind of
that emotional intelligence to be able
to kind of understand those boundaries
women should take responsibility to in
how they are interacting with men but I
also believe and men should as well but
I think that now because of such a it's
a geyser afraid to even like approach
women nowadays and and not saying that
you should at work you know like hit on
your you know secretary but I think that
it's crossed a line now where it's
almost it's taking away from like normal
human connection and where is that
balance of you know me too to
building friendships and building a
human connection mentorship there's a
ton of men in my corporate when I had my
corporate life that were legit business
mentors like yourself who's made money
and who can teach me some things I think
that there's there's some the atmosphere
is tense right now between men and women
well can you touch on something you said
you said that men are afraid to approach
women these days is is that an overall
sentiment that you guys have is that men
are afraid to approach you for fear of
getting me too does that something
uh are we saying it in the workplace
yeah I I believe that this whole toxic
masculinity post-feminist era has really
destroyed men being men and now they
don't feel that they can pursue they
don't feel that they can be confident in
their advances if that's deemed too much
you know like
like my dad showed up at my Mom's
doorstep when they were first dating
nowadays like that would someone would
think that's like a stalker but like to
my mom that was love you know it's like
there's been such a difference now and I
think that men have been had to dial it
back and then women have to be the
crossroads and we don't want to be the
aggressors like I don't want to be
pursuing a guy I want to be pursued but
so many times
just the initial approach then you let
him take it from there and yeah but I
think that in such this again
post-feminist era and toxic masculinity
I think we do need to go back to
traditional
you saw them traditional gender roles of
you know men shouldn't be afraid to
approach a woman that they are
interested in or ask them out so if you
like that clip click right here to watch
another or if you want to watch the
entire saucecast click right here
foreign